[Music]
[Applause]
uh Mike klis he covers the Broncos for
nine news kind enough to get up and join
us here early in the morning if we
didn't watch the game Mike how would you
sum up what happened last night
yeah going along with the theme you just
uh introduced their Amazon delivered
America box of doo doo you know that was
uh that was bad
um bad offensive football I guess it's
uh insulting to the defenses that you
know you call it overall a real ugly
terrible game
but the NFL is about offense now they
changed all the rules to make it
favorable for the offense and uh they
couldn't get anything going it's hard to
believe that you know going into that
game had you hyped it a couple weeks ago
or maybe a couple months ago you know
Matt Ryan and and Russell Wilson one day
are going in the Hall of Fame yeah and
uh they came up with that performance I
thought Matt Ryan for the longest time
looked like a washed up quarterback
and then Russell Wilson at the end made
some
uh some horrific uh
ghastly interceptions that were that
were costly it was just it was just a
bad product he had Bronco fans booing
and uh how well how often does that
happen Mike
the Bronco fans booing during a game
when you're leading
yeah it's been happening increasingly in
the last couple of years this team uh
you know there for what a 30-year
stretch during the bowling era had uh
more Super Bowl appearances
uh seven than losing Seasons five
and uh so the standards have been raised
um you know kind of like the cup fans in
in Chicago and the Red Sox fans in
Boston once you taste success uh the
standards are raised and uh this year
it's gotten worse though you know it got
worse with that with the mocking
counting down in the play clock in the
in the Houston game
and now this is a pretty critical fan
base and they're not liking what they
see
explained to me what was going on when
they went for the touchdown instead of
an anemic Colts offense that if you go
for the field goal they still have to
score a touchdown and an extra point to
beat you and your defenses played well I
I didn't understand the logic and Mike I
thought ego may have played in this that
maybe coaching quarterback said we got
to get a touchdown here just to save
face here because you do have the game
you're going to be up by six at home and
they have no timeouts left I I just
didn't understand the logic yeah no
timeouts you're running down the clock
to the two minute warning so you're
kicking the field goal to go up six
the Colts get the ball with about 152.
and uh they went to put the game away
you know that was uh the decision to
make you can't throw an interception
there obviously
but if you're running the ball and and
taking the six that six point lead that
is
um you're not you're not risking that
um I think
Hackett was probably confident that
Russell Wilson wouldn't throw up a pick
there
and you know Russell saw things there uh
with Tyree Cleveland who's
you know he's barely been on the field
this season he's there now he was their
number five number six receiver last
night and to go to him
on you know on a post pattern you know
that that was a head scratcher and no
doubt and then that was one big decision
and the other one was the uh fourth and
one at the five
and uh they were under Center it looked
like they were going to run the ball for
the first down
which of course they could have done and
then gone goal to go from before or the
three yard line and they went for it all
right there
and of course Russ uh
went over the middle and
was it Gilmore again that knocked it
away yeah so yeah you know he was the
wrong guy to go after I just didn't
understand that that and Kirk Herbstreit
said it in the moment they went to the
line of scrimmage and it was like we're
going to get the playoff quickly and
then you know you're gonna you're gonna
get the first down and then they call
time out and I thought yeah they said
they didn't like the look of the India
that's what Hackett said when they when
they went up to the line they didn't
like the uh
the look of uh the Colts defense for
their running play that they had called
so they um and and that play that they
call that's uh uh one of Russ's favorite
plays you know they work on it in
practice that's Hackett likes to play uh
Russell Wilson likes to play I just
think in the in the that pressurized
moment
um
you know Russ didn't didn't go right you
know hamler came off that pick
but uh Russ never looked that way and uh
the result was what it was I just
mentioned we're talking to Mike Cliff
who covers the Broncos for nine news in
Denver I mentioned that over the last 28
years 18 coaches have been one and done
and I don't know you know the Walton
family didn't hire Nathaniel Hackett uh
you can't fire the quarterback how much
pressure is
Nathaniel Hackett facing here right now
you know I was asked that on radio
before the game and I I said there's no
way
and uh that you know that the Walmart
family
uh didn't become Walmart by uh firing
people with you know four-year contracts
you know half year into year one with
four-year contracts uh and eating you
know seven million a year or whatever it
is for a coach
and the Walmart family uh didn't
hire uh Nathaniel Hackett but they
bought the team and put up 4.65 billion
knowing he was the coach
um
because the you know the the sale they
won the bidding process in June after he
was there after Wilson was there
everything looked pretty good there in
June
um
I don't think I think Hackett
we'll get two years I mean this is uh
around here we kind of go back to 2012
Peyton's first year here
they were also two and three
after five games and in game six they
were down 24 to nothing going into the
San Diego at halftime of the San Diego
game
and they got it together in the second
half they rallied to win they won 11 in
a row now I don't see that with this
team uh right now but uh I guess the
point to make here is it's it's still
early you still have
a new quarterback even if he is a
veteran uh trying to adjust to a new
offensive system with the with the first
year coach
and um they're both you know the first
year coach is going through some growing
pains and
you know he hired Jerry Rossford to help
him with the game management and I think
overall the game management has been
okay you can question the decisions
still
um at crunch time
but uh you know the operation seems to
be much better uh since rosberg has got
there but um
I I guess the short answer is I think
hackett's gonna get
two years of this four-year deal you
know they keep changing coaches here Dan
uh since 2016 they've had Kubiak Joseph
uh fangio and now hack and all they do
is fire coaches
you know at some point you got to um
you know let the coach uh develop on the
job if you're going to hire first-year
guys which is what they've done if
you're going to hire first-time coaches
at some point you got to let them
develop and grow
good to talk to you and uh good luck
against the Chargers next Monday night
thank you Mike
thanks appreciate it that's my class he
covers the Broncos 9 news
that sounded hopeless yeah it did yeah
that was really like yeah depressing I'm
not even a Bronco fan I'm bummed